[Music]
our next speaker
in this theme is dr irfan ibrahim
he joins us from the united states of
america and he's the founder and ceo of
the big bazaar
over to your fun hello
my name is erfan ibrahim and i'm the
founder and ceo
of the bit bazaar llc in california
usa today i'm going to be
comparing different predictive models
for covert 19.
my background is that i have a bs in
physics from syracuse university
a master's in mechanical engineering
from the university of texas at austin
and a phd in nuclear engineering from
the university of california at berkeley
i've worked extensively in
physical sciences and mathematics and
engineering
i have worked also in the field of
energy
networking and cyber security
during these years i have done a lot of
work in mathematical modeling
and over the last 33 years since my
doctorate
i have worked at lawrence livermore lab
pacific bell
the bit bazaar the electric power
research institute
and the national renewable energy lab
i've also spent some time as a research
engineer
at ucla
i do a lot of public speaking in science
and technology
i also give presentations on business
process
and on policy currently i
am running the bit bazaar llc as a cyber
security consulting company
the covert 19 disease
has spread globally and as you can see
we have over 23 million people infected
as of august 23rd 2020
with over 800 000 deaths and some 15
million people have recovered
the four nations that we see that have
the highest level of infection
are usa with 5.7 million
brazil with 3.6 million india
with 3 million and russia with 952
000. these countries
started the the growth of the infection
started at different times
in the u.s it started pretty early in
march
and in brazil india and russia it
happened subsequently in the may june
time frame
if we look at the infection data across
the globe
here are some statistics on the number
of
infections and you can see how
brazil usa and india
are disproportionately representative of
the virus
covert 19 virus while there are
several other countries that have a lot
of infections
but proportionally looking at this
brazil
usa and india and to some extent russia
are leading
if we look at the fatality data in terms
of number of deaths
you see some countries like italy france
and spain
are also showing large numbers of debts
as well as brazil usa india and russia
and if you look at the clinical fatality
rate which
is basically the clinical
death numbers divided by the clinical
infections that are documented
you can see that italy and france and
spain
are leading in the clinical fatality
rate
there are several reasons for
the high clinical fatality rate if
the patients were over 60 years of age
had co-morbidities
the percentage of patients that die from
covert 19
is pretty high also certain countries
have better health care than
other countries and you see variations
in the clinical fatality rate based on
the quality of health care
also the number depends on the extent of
testing
so the more testing that is done
the larger the percentage of people that
got covert 19 would be documented
and then that would lower the clinical
fatality rate significantly
and also how are the debts
documented in the death certificates
there may be situations
where the patient has some comorbidity
and died as a result of that and it
could be documented as a covert 19 death
or there was a patient who died
and there was no covert 19 test done and
was just presumed
based on epidemiological data
that this person may have had covert
so all of these factors affect
the accuracy of the clinical fatality
rate
there are many reliability challenges
with covert 19 statistical data the
first is that there is no global
standard for covert 19 statistical data
collection
every country and even within the
country every province or state
and even down to the individual
hospitals have their own unique ways of
documenting
the patients that come in and those who
recover
those who die and that data is then
compiled and sent
to a state or provincial level and
eventually to the national level
but in the absence of a global standard
there's tremendous variability
in the accuracy of that data
there's also tremendous geographical
variability in the extent of testing of
infected people
some countries like south korea and
germany and iceland and new zealand
you see very very extensive testing
done on the suspected population
and then other countries not so much
so there's tremendous geographical
variability
and then as i mentioned in the previous
slide
a lot of deaths are occurring in
hospitals
and there are symptoms similar to covert
19 in the patients
but it's not clear whether they had
covert 19
or some other respiratory illness that
was the cause of death so
in many hospitals as many as 30
of the deaths that have been documented
as coveted 19
are actually in the absence of a test
and just based on assumptions based on
epidemiological data
also the testing since this is after all
a new strain of the virus the tests are
not very reliable
and you see that with both the pcr type
of testing and the antibody testing
that there's extensive amounts of false
positive and false negative
results from the patients when
they are tested on proven patients
of having it or not having it and then
you see
as much as 50 error rates
and then also there are quite a few
people
who never come to the hospital who may
have caught this
covert 19 and they recovered at home and
there's no
medical data for them also
if someone died at home and didn't get
medical attention they're often not
counted
in the medical records so the bottom
line is that
there is no credible data to empirically
calculate the clinical or biological
fatality rate from covert 19
and this is a source of tremendous
frustration
for the researchers because they can't
quite put their finger
on what is happening in a particular
region
or a particular country and it's all
very much guessing game
so we look at some of the
comparisons of some of the models that
have been developed
i developed a model for calculating
the biological fatality rate in the u.s
and i based that on some of the data we
were getting in
new york state in the initial stages in
march and i found that
the clinical fatality rate at the time
was around two and a half percent
but for every one patient that was
admitted in the hospital
four others were asked to go home
without any testing done
and asked to recover at home because
their symptoms were not so severe
so i took the two and a half percent
clinical fatality rate divided it by
five
to come up with a biological fatality
rate
of 0.5 because the 4 out of 5
were not included in the stats for the
total number of people infected
so the clinical fatality rate was
artificially high
because of the lack of total coverage of
the number of infected people in the
denominator of that ratio
and then i also estimated that on
average it takes about
18 days between the time a person gets
infected and the time of their death
if they were to die from covert 19.
and if you look at the lancet report
that came out in april of 2020
they calculated after all the
corrections the fatality rate of 0.6
percent
so it was very close to the 0.5 percent
i had
estimated a week or two before
and also the cdc has now
recently released data that says that
the biological fatality rate may be
closer to 0.6
validating what the lancet report in my
model showed
months ago and also there was a lancet
report on some
patients in wuhan in china
that suggested that if a person were to
die from covert 19
that they would die somewhere between 15
and 22 days from the day they were
infected
so the 18 as an average of 15 to 22 was
a good
average stanford university in early
april
also developed a model based on
the patients that they gathered from
santa clara county here in california
usa
there were 3 350 blood samples collected
and the people were brought in through
facebook
and also they found that one point
five percent of the people tested
positive for covet 19
they corrected for the fact that
these people were of certain ethnicities
and there was a gender bias towards
females
and so after all those corrections they
said somewhere between
2.49 to 4.16
of the population in santa clara had
been
infected by early april
and if you take the population
of the county at 1.93 million
we're talking about somewhere between 48
000 to 80
000 people infected by early april
so what that did was it really reduced
the biological
fatality rate for santa clara county
based on these measurements and
calculations so the biological fatality
rate
was somewhere between 0.12
to 0.2 assuming that 100 people
would have died by april 22nd because it
typically takes
almost three weeks from the time they
get infected
to when they could potentially die
so based on the stanford university
covert 19 model of april
if you take the current number of deaths
in santa clara county
at 224 the estimated number of people
infected is somewhere between a hundred
and twelve thousand
and a hundred and eighty seven thousand
and so the one eighty seven
thousand is a little less than ten
percent
of the santa clara county population
and that could be realistic for this
county
given that the infection came early
and that there are a lot of dense areas
of urban population in this county
and the number of people
that have been exposed since the county
opened up
to the third level where there's outdoor
dining
and there are people gathering in
commercial areas
that could potentially be true
now we look at the comparison of the
various models for the usa
and we find that at the moment we have
about 5.7 million
people infected with 176 000
deaths the landsat model would take that
176 000 deaths and project that
29.3 million people in the u.s
are infected and that would be a little
less than
10 percent of the population and that is
pretty realistic
the stanford model on the other hand
with the 0.12
2.2 fatality rate would estimate
somewhere between
88 million and 147 million people
currently
having the covet infection or have
haven't been exposed to it and that
seems a bit
on the high end because the population
of the u.s is about 330 million
and nowhere close to a quarter to
half of the u.s is infected at the time
the empirical evidence is just not there
so the stanford model is a bit on the
high end
and the landsat model seems to be
reasonable
based on the empirical evidence of
disease spread in certain u.s
communities
now i'm going to take you through some
models that were developed for
india and then compare them with the
lancet
and stanford models to see how
the various models are faring after four
or five months
of disease spread so we'll start with
the
indian council for medical research icmr
and it predicted that somewhere between
one and ten percent of the population
could get infected in india by the time
the peak hits
and this is called an s-e-i-r
model where s is the susceptibility to
the disease is the people exposed i is
the number of infected
and r is the number of people recovered
so if we take
the population of india at 1.34 billion
and estimate 1 to 10 percent that is
somewhere between 13.4 million
and 134 million people infected
by the peak in india
and if we say we're getting close to the
peak we can now
compare it with the models
for landsat and stanford and see that
currently there are three million people
infected clinically
based on medical records and 57
000 deaths based on the current hospital
stats
so if you look at 3 million infected
compared to 13.4 million and 134 million
it still hasn't hit that range that the
icmr predicts
however if we take the biological
rate of the biological fatality rate
of 0.6 for lancet then
it estimates that for 57
000 deaths we're looking at nine and a
half million people infected
which is getting close to the low end of
the icmr
range and also the stanford model
estimates somewhere between 28.5 and
47.5 million people infected
based on the 57 000 deaths and the
biological fatality rate of 0.12
to 0.2 percent and so that is well
within
the range that the icmr is predicting
if we take the michigan model that
is a susceptibility infection recovery
model
and it's saying that in the absence of
any intervention
india could have 16 cases out of 10 000
people at the peak
and if you take the 1.34 billion
this translates to 2.14
million people could be infected at the
peak based on the michigan model
and so the 3 million infected today
has already exceeded that number and if
we take the 57 000
debts and apply it on the lancet model
and the stanford model
you see that nine and a half million
means that we've already crossed that in
the lancet model
and in the sanford model also we are
well above
what the prediction of the michigan
model was so
what we're finding is that the actual
infections that are documented as well
as the two u.s
models would suggest that we've
gone way past the estimate of the
michigan model
recall that the michigan model was
developed back
in the april may time frame and
they had absolutely no idea of how this
thing was going to spread
and how quickly it was going to spread
over the
summer months next model is the john
hopkins model
and this is india's sim
model with epidemiological modeling with
agent-based modeling
and it includes demographic
considerations to develop covert 19
forecasts for different parts of india
so there's tremendous sensitivity in
this model
to the different provinces and it also
it has the idea of different age groups
and
and looks at the demographic
distribution in the different provinces
to predict the amount of infection and
amount of deaths
so in this model they've determined
that somewhere between 10 and 25 million
people could get infected sometime
between
march and august and we see
that we haven't gotten close to that in
the documented
infections there are only three million
up to now and
based on the 57 000 debts
the lancet model is showing nine and a
half million
so that's getting close to the low end
of the johns hopkins
prediction and the stanford model says
somewhere between
28.5 million and 47.5 million
so we are slightly higher than the range
predicted by the johns hopkins model
the next model is the cambridge
university model
and this is also susceptibility
infection
recovery model and it compartmentalizes
people into the three groups based on
age brackets
and the different rates of infection
based on lifestyle so
if they're living in large communal
housing
then it would spread more and if they're
more in detached homes
then it would spread less and where they
spend time
their leisure so this
says this cambridge university model
says
that if there were a 48-day
shelter increased program that the
virus would stop spreading and this
assumes that
by 48 days the virus is pretty much
not viable anymore in most patients
and so they remained in place and they
didn't spread it to each other
and even if they spread it within their
household people would recover
within 48 days and then there would be
no way for them to spread it to anyone
else
so based on this model they predicted
that 2727 people could potentially die
from covert 19 if the shelter in place
was limited to 21 days
but it assumed that if it went for the
full 48 days
that only a handful of people would die
but that wasn't the case we had 70 days
of
lockdown in india
after many extensions starting out with
the three weeks and then
they had two or three other extensions
until
they were shut down for a good 10 weeks
and even despite that lockdown for that
long a period
of time three million people were
infected
57 000 deaths so the
number of deaths that have already
occurred are 19
times more even after
there was 49 more days of lockdown
than the 21 days that was
based in the model so that shows clearly
that there are a lot of flaws in the
assumptions
made in these models of how people get
infected
the clinical results tell a truth
that cannot be denied and so that is why
it is important to constantly
review the assumptions of models and see
if there's something we can do to
improve
on the assumptions
so the concluding remarks that i have is
one is that these predictive models are
not very reliable
the problem that we're having is that
there's so many variables
and each model makes a certain set of
assumptions
that there's tremendous variability in
what
those models conclude also
there is a great limitation in both the
extent of the testing as well as in the
accuracy
of the testing and so the empirical data
on infection rates
is not very reliable
and also the lockdowns when we see
spain and france and uk
and germany the lockdowns and
also china and south korea the lockdowns
were very effective
but then when we see countries like the
united states
or brazil or india we find that the
lockdowns are not very successful
and that despite the number of days
there's so much leakage
that people get infected when they're
outside
they come home and they spread the virus
to their families
then some family member with the
infection goes out
and the same thing happens again so
the extent of the
disease in terms of time duration just
keeps getting longer and longer
because there just isn't the absolute
seal of the viruses and then we find
also that the clinical fatality rates
for the various reasons i mentioned
earlier in the presentation
vary a lot across the globe and
naturally the biological fatality rate
that we see from the stanford model
as well as the lancet model my model
as well as certain countries where there
was very very detailed testing
is that the biological fatality rate is
a lot lower
than the six to ten percent uh that is
the clinical fatality rate
and also in the last uh i'd say one to
two months
we're seeing a resurgence in the
infections in many
countries that had lockdowns set up
for the months of march april and may
so that shows that it doesn't take very
much
for this virus to come back and start
spreading again
in the absence of a vaccine and in the
absence of
sufficient social distancing
so in conclusion i would like to
thank dr shahid jameel who
i co-authored a paper with that is the
basis of this presentation
and i'd like to thank all observer
research foundation in india
that published our paper and there is a
link here on the slide
for finding that paper and i would also
like
to thank the organization merck kgaa
for inviting me to speak at this
conference
my contact information is provided here
with both email and phone number and i
look forward to your comments after
you've seen
this presentation and answer any
questions that you may have
thank you and have a safe
and wonderful fall season thank you
thank you dr abraham for a great
presentation that was the final
presentation
of theme two now please join us for a
live q a with all the speakers